je voulais revenir sur quelque chose
parce que la semaine dernière je lui ai
dit qu'on avait le cousin de cyril
engels a pas ou alors si laurent ournac
est avec nous sauf que du coup on fait
toute la semaine on m'a dit super bonne
blague très drôle c'était drôle personne
n'a cru que vous étiez le cousin de
cyril hanouna et c'est vrai et pourtant
et pourtant mais c'est vrai ou pas c'est
vrai les cousins cousin comme en cause
un acquis du côté du papa de cheryl donc
l'un de ses reins à ganges ils sont
cousins germains mais le ton père c'est
le frère y mélange donc tout à fait
dangereux perdu siribala fait ça donc
vous êtes vraiment cousin germain saint
germain est donc voté par petits bouts
jolie lançant vous étiez projet et en
plus j'ai une très très belle anecdote
non moi à chaque grade mais si je peux
me permettre as-tu attention c'est
une période de quelques années de ça
ouais j'étais vivre chez eux chez ses
parents pourquoi concours de
circonstance jacques or un peu donc j
espère et son prêt des examens et il m'a
proposé d'aller faire une petite partie
de tennis ouais que j'ai pas pu refuser
parce que c'était mon petit poussin
ouais donc j'étais avec lui c'était en
plein été ouais du mois et on a été donc
on a réservé un court de tennis et du
niveau qu'on doit aller où la chute
comment faire échanger quelques balles
ouais c'est principe du tennis
donc avait un court juste à côté ouais
tout ça donc on a demandé quelle météo
saison là bas qu'elle mettait
là il ne nous rejoindra noble à tanger
bct qui je ne sais pas ah ah merde
vingtaine avec 2,2 fuchs était mcenroe
et wilander on connaissait pas attendez
attendez vrai ça vient donc qui sont
venus nous rejoindre donc on a commencé
à faire un double ouais hein on a
commencé à échanger quelques balles oui
d'accord l'info
vraiment comment j'allais très vite
ouais et un moment syrie s'est arrêté de
jouer 1 pourquoi c'est pas rien dit il
s'est assis sur la chaussée la soul là
je sens pas du tout cette attitude
radicale assis sur le banc donc il
faisait chaud et tout et il y avait un
petit souci une gastro c'est qu'ils
commençaient à se gratter inspire du bas
du vent
là on va alors est ce qui s'est passé là
c'est passé pour ne pas perturber la
partie qui s'est mis à poil bah il a
enlevé d'une short gênant et son caleçon
il est venu jouer mais n'ont ni
christine une enquête dont qui faisait
coup droit avec la table
ce qui s'est passé on y reste et tous
les trois bah bah voilà window qui était
déjà tard et il a joué lui il a commencé
voilà élaguer et donc forcément un avc
ont été arrêtés on est resté baba donc
on n'a pas pu continuer la question
contenu dans l'oreillette évidemment je
pète la pause est vraiment ils sont nuls
en régie à la haye les bienfaits laraque
était
la raquette était comme hors du temps
elle est normale laraque est normal
normal c'est déjà bien et bien monter
car à côté général la mairie se casse
pas laisser ces familles alain c'est
normal c'est familial et c'est normal
chez nous assez facile et normal on
parle de la taille de ton propre mais je
traînais honorine aux reptiles
dis moi comment peut-il était comment
est-ce que tu sentais que petit il est
tout le temps chaud y est allé bouffer
allait devenir la terre qui les oublie t
il était assez agitée du nord regarde sa
tête mahbod thurso maïté millions mon
salaire
la cassette
on a mal
à chaque fin de mois je pense à lui
olala ok j'ai toujours était beau ce que
tu sentais qu'il devient une star ou pas
franchement ouais il était prédisposé du
loup mais non pourquoi pas ce qu'il y a
cru il ya des gens comme ça c'est en eux
tu crois cci n'est exactement ce qu'il
faisait son père talentueux en médecine
et intérêts et aventure à talentueux
métier avec une aventure ouais non mais
j'en donnerai pas mon temps sont pas là
il est déjà ils étaient ni ce qu'on
attendait avec les meufs raconte paquet
mais parce qu'il jure qu'il n'a pas
désigné gnagna non non j'ai jamais dit
qu'il avait pas dit non non je suis mal
acquis les raquettes de tennis j'avais
dit ça me choper des mêmes histoires et
choper des meufs ou pas mais qu'on
constate comme tout le monde non non non
ça aussi ça comme tout bon je sais bien
que galère ces familles est alors en
arrête de vendre et balance il accusait
la mi-session ramène à lui est ce que du
show père oui des mails bah oui
de tous
[Applaudissements]
oui ça s'appelle que l'on leur porte
monnaie une femme ouais avoir que des
belles c'est parce que je dit en train
de vous dire qu'à cyril hanouna pour la
france entière a joué au boudin ouais
pas du tout béton des belles et des
moins belles et des mois mais les
soutiens de famille tout le monde oui
bah non jean michel david et moi des
belles et des mois mais elles doivent
éviter toutes rattachées aux pays bas
non mais voilà et il est généreux que
rémy il est très fine très généreux
passé les vaccins fragments de poésie
l'arrivée de pas céder et encore
aujourd'hui il t'amène sur sa voiture
aujourd'hui un peu moins et ça nous est
arrivé des gens c'est vrai oui des fois
respectée et pourquoi il m'a appelé pour
me dire mon cousin veut faire de la télé
tu en sais rien a été fait de manière
ouais naturel à tanger de la question de
poser presque à l'arrêt crise battait
tout le temps
c'était un même que même calculé où
paris vient assez agitée adam est un peu
plus âgé que lui mais bon il dalet
j'avais toujours des répercussions vu
qu'on on était très famille et on monte
notre grand mère
paternelle donc la grand-mère le
réprimander à chaque fois
voilà donc j'étais un petit peu au
courant des charges de police ou pas
parfois et non
il a un casier judiciaire surtout non
non non il n'a jamais rien volé une
voiture a toujours rien et tu sais quoi
je m'arrête embêter avec s'arrête non
mais il ya une qualité un défaut de
cyril il ya beaucoup de coeur non à la
qualité beaucoup de coeur ouais y'a des
fous très persévérant c'est pas un
défaut
mais marvel et moi moi des fois il était
non mais il ya un défaut un défaut il
est très speed mon nom est faux mais
c'est bien quatre pattes et émissions en
tant que j'aurais pas dit oui c'est ça
des faussaires à taxer si comme il s'en
veut quelques-uns
autoritaire dans le
jeu de dominos ne donne pas de défauts
sans émission
famille qualité des photos cyril toi moi
une qualité habib à qualité rapide
fidélité les efforts rapides autoritaire
tour marché de fer et gravats là eh ben
voilà